hi
i'm brandon royal solution manager and
technical strategist for cicd
and antho solutions here at google cloud
i'm joined by my colleague ben good
solution architect and devops expert
also
during today's session we'll discuss
some of the common challenges that
customers see
when it comes to modernizing their ci cd
especially around
hybrid cloud deployments that
infrastructure
we'll review some of the core principles
that we think about when architecting
and modernizing ci cd solutions with
enterprise customers
and finally we'll discuss how anthos can
be leveraged
within your environment to build more
robust consistent pipelines across not
only on-prem
as well as hybrid cloud environments
enable those pipelines for not only
application configuration but also
policies
and configuration and ultimately help
your application teams to deploy code
faster now cicd is not a new concept
it's been on for at least a decade and a
lot of the tools and practices
really haven't changed that much what
has changed quite significantly
is the infrastructure surrounding cicd
so specifically we've moved from a more
imperative
infrastructure where we're describing
all the changes that we need to do
within our pipelines to more of a
declarative infrastructure
not only for our applications but also
our underlying infrastructure and
security policies
now security security often has a very
different operating model from
developers
and operations and we see that as a
point of friction within a lot of our
customers
and then we also are seeing very
inconsistent tools between
on-premises deployments of ci cd and
cloud deployments
many of our customers describe that they
have one very different set of tools for
managing deploying the test build uh
automation for
their cloud-based applications and a
very different one for
on-premises and we all know there's
manual processes that are involved
in especially configuration changes
across environments
and we find that's a huge issue when
creating those inconsistencies
especially between multiple cloud
environments
now gallop's research and assessment the
organization that brings you the state
of downpour
published some really interesting
findings when it comes to devops
performance
this report has tons and tons of details
but some of the most important parts are
devops performance is directly
correlated with organizational
performance
so improving the performance of your ci
cd pipelines
the pace at which you're deploying your
code a time in which it takes you to
recover from
any service degradation is directly
correlated to your organization's
performance
also the selection of cloud-based tools
have a very meaningful impact
in your ability to be a high performer
within those key devops metrics
and the last in this course isn't going
to be surprising to anyone organizations
that are using
more slow uh change management approval
processes using standard ticketing based
methods
often don't uh perform as well as those
that are using more
get ups based methods that's what we're
going to talk a little bit about today
now when we think about modernizing ci
cd we think about these five principles
first we look at security so security is
not only in terms of how we create a
secure pipeline but also how do we
create very clear
separation of duties between developers
operators and secure
and we'll talk specifically about what
those responsibilities are
we want to ensure that we're securing
the pipeline through vulnerability
management and
at the station so we're able to
cryptographically sign our images
as they go from build to test to deploy
and we want to manage the entire process
using robust access control
now we talked a little bit about
imperative versus declarative
infrastructure
we want to manage all of our
configurations from application
configuration down to infrastructure
configuration
as code that allows us to have a single
auditable source of truth
for all of our applications and also
gives us a
clean git based interface in which we
can manage all those configurations
we want to drive automation of course
that's what cicd is all about
but we not only want to look at
automating our code deployment process
but also our security
policy process so the way in which we
are
managing those security configurations
across multi-clustered environments
is critical to automate as well and we
want to leverage
containers wherever possible not only
for the applications
because that was going to provide that
isolated extensible environment but also
for our actual
build infrastructure itself google has a
significant commitment to kubernetes
open source ecosystem
and we want to ensure that we're
providing open standards-based
interfaces for
all of our ci cd infrastructure allowing
you to leverage the existing investments
that you have in place today
so what does that mean ultimately that
that process of modernizing your ci cd
practices with anthos
is going to help your developers to
reduce burden and focus on value-added
tasks
developing code and providing to your
customers it will help you to establish
better governance across your entire
cicd process
and allow you to share those best
practices between development
teams so one development team can
benefit from the innovation of another
and finally we want to provide and this
solution ultimately will help
provide flexibility to deploy those same
configurations
across cloud environments as well as
underground environments
so when we think about cicd it's more
than just the ci cd pipelines themselves
cicd pipelines are absolutely important
in our testing process and our
deployment process
but we also want to think about what's
below this surface and very similar to a
bridge structure where
below the roadway there's all kinds of
complexities in
managing the structure bridge itself of
the roadway itself
we want to think about cicd in a very
similar way
where the underlying structure is our
platform configuration and our
management
and our ability to manage those
configurations across environments
and ultimately to orchestrate and
automate the underlying infrastructure
that supports
our applications and our ci cd platforms
the way we do this is we break down the
problem into
components so we talk about this in
terms of the cicd component taxonomy
these are the major components that
anyone needs to think about when they're
deploying
a cicd process and we want to ensure
with this
methodology you're able to leverage
existing components that you might
have in place already including things
like application observability
you might have robust cd pipelines that
you want to continue to use or
maybe even ci pipelines so this solution
allows you to plug in
these existing investments and manage
them on top of an emphasis
for that ultimate consistency
when we talk about various stakeholders
in the organization
generally we talk about developers
operators and security
each one has slightly different goals
when it comes to modernizing their
approach to ci cd
the operations teams are here to
standardize how application teams are
onboarded
and how those applications are managed
over time
the security team has a new set of
challenges they ultimately need to
inject and propagate all those those
application
policies and configurations of not only
one environment but multiple
environments potentially spread across
multiple clouds
and then developers we talked about
developers needing to focus
on developing and providing so we want
to reduce the burden for those
developers wherever possible
and allow them to provide that value as
quickly as possible
one of the ways in which we do that in
this solution is to provide standard
interfaces these all open standard
interfaces that we use
in order to plug in those existing
components into the kubernetes ecosystem
wherever possible the first is standard
git based interfaces
now git allows us to have that git based
or git ops based
process where by which we are we are
deploying
all of our code and configurations
directly through
git repositories the second is container
based images
ultimately we can describe our
application but also our infrastructure
using standard oci based images and
alaska
these are all ultimately kubernetes
objects anthos provides that kubernetes
platform
and using things like amphos
configuration
management that allows us to manage
those kubernetes manifests
across multiple environments so let's
talk a little bit about the workflow
some of these aspects will seem very
familiar to those of you who are already
deploying ci cd workflows within your
enterprise environments
the first is the developer order flow we
want to allow our developers to start
with their application code repository
and use a continuous integration
pipeline to build to test
and ultimately deploy into a staged
environment
this pipeline will build our container
images and we'll push them
into a container registry
now next up is our operator now our
operator in this case is going to start
with not the application code repository
but a different repository
specifically designed to share code best
practices
now this repository will contain all of
the shared standards for
various applications that might be
deployed within the enterprise and that
operator can use
inheritance models that we'll talk about
here shortly to
manage the configuration delta between
what's deployed in the
developers application and what's
managed in the best practices repository
the operator will trigger a pipeline
specifically designed for
rendering all of the configurations so
using a tool like customize or like help
we can actually take multiple
configurations that might be shared
across
our shared best practices repository and
the application repository
and render them into fully hydrated
manifests in what we call
our environment repository an
environment repository
is our single source of truth that's
where we can audit all of our
configurations
as we'll see in the demo we can see all
of these specific configurations
even down to the hashes of our images
that are deployed in various
environments and then last and certainly
not least
our security they need to use a amp
those configuration management
repository or acm repository
to manage not only their infrastructure
configuration but also their policies
which will be then propagated to uh to
the clusters
uh using anthos configuration management
now as far as the application
configurations are concerned
again we want to start with a shared set
of best practices
so that allows us to use things like a
base configuration for using customize
in this case to describe what are the
common configurations that we might have
across our application
and most applications there's lots of
similarities that we might have so we
want to share those best practices
essentially
the second repository the application
code repository that's where we're going
to patch
those configurations so anything above
and beyond
those baseline configurations that's
where we're going to specify those
things like
the images or any additional port
configuration or
or other application specific
configuration that we might have applied
ultimately that will render a fully
hydrated manifest again
that then gets stored within our
environment repository
giving us that single source of truth so
that's the application
workflow what about the security
workflow
now security workflow is all about
policy management
so we of course manage our underlying
infrastructure but the
core responsibility of security in this
context
is managing the propagation of various
policies
those can be anything from pod security
policies to
firewall policies anything that
describes the behavior to essentially
provide guardrails to
application teams is what we define as a
policy
now these are ultimately stored directly
as kubernetes objects
and are handled by amp ampdos
configuration management
so under the hood anthous configuration
management is listening to that kit
repository
and allows our security teams in
coordination with our operations teams
and development teams
to push those policies and
configurations acm takes care of the
rest
taking those configurations and properly
propagating them
across those clusters allowing for full
code review
continuous integration and full
integration into
development now ecosystem just a little
bit about how that works i'm going to
hand it over to ben
thanks brandon let's take a look at the
demo
let's take a look at a couple of the
workflows that brandon was just
describing
in the cicd on anthos presentation
so before we dig into the exact into the
workflows let's take a look at the gke
clusters
that we have deployed and what we'll be
using them for
so we have four clusters that we'll be
using to run
our applications the first is a dev
cluster
so in the demo we'll use scaffold to
automatically detect the changes to the
application code and then
deploy them into the dev cluster this
will enable us to live test
our changes on the dev cluster before we
push them into the repository
from there once when they're pushed into
the main line of the application code
repository a deployment is automatically
kicked off
which deploys our changes to the staging
cluster
then once when we validated our changes
in the staging cluster
we can merge the environment
configuration
from the staging branch into the
mainline branch
which would trigger the production
deployment to our two production
clusters
uh the fifth cluster that we have out
here is used for
shared services so on that cluster we're
running git lab
and that's where we'll be storing our
source code and running our cacd
pipelines
so now let's pretend that i'm an
application developer
and i have a simple go application if we
take a look at that
we see that it simply outputs hello
world
and my task is to update
that reading this output from hello
world to something else
so as a as a good developer what we'll
do is we'll start by creating a new
branch
we'll call it new greeting
and before i start making changes here i
want to
get scaffold started so it's connected
up to our development cluster
let's first make sure that we're in the
right context here
there you go
so scaffold is going to watch our source
code
and as it changes it's automatically
going to build new versions of the
container
push them into artifact registry and
then run
deployments on those of those new
container images out to our deployment
our development cluster so that way we
can test
so we can see here that scaffold is up
and running
and if we preview
we can see hello world is output so now
we're ready to get started with our
changes
so we'll go to our editor here
so we're going to say hello google
on air so that'll be our new greeting
so we can see as i've changed back to
cloud shell that scaffold has detected
that change and it's already starting to
rebuild the image
okay now the image has been deployed so
if we refresh
in our browser ah there's our new
greeting
and that looks good so we're ready to
push our changes
into our source control system and
kick off the cacd pipelines
so let's stop scaffold here
and we'll commit our changes
and then we'll push them out
okay so now if we go over into
git lab
and we log in as the developer here
me in this case
okay we can see that i just pushed a new
branch so let's go ahead and create a
merge request
so at this point what's happening is
we're running a ci pipeline
on our branch and we are tech
running tests we're gonna hydrate the
manifests
and we're gonna validate the manifest as
well so we're running
uh a subset of the stages that will run
later on so everything except for the
deployment part of the pipeline
so this is giving us the opportunity to
validate any manifest changes that we
might have made
in the application code repository as
well as any application code changes
and we'll just have git lab merge when
it succeeds
okay so we can see through the comments
here that
everything is merged
so if we look at our ci cd pipelines
we're now running
another pipeline so in this one we're
running tests again
we're gonna build our new image
and we're going to hydrate and validate
configs
and then we're going to push those
configs into our environment repository
so while we wait for this to run let's
take a quick look
at our repository and what we have in
here
so in here we have our source code so
our main.go
with our greeting we have our docker
file and then we have
some kubernetes manifest so these
manifests are the changes that we want
to make
so in this case we're setting the
environment to dev
for each environment and if we look at
staging
or production we can see that we're also
setting the environment to prod
so these changes are getting merged
together
with the common shared best practices
that are stored
in this shared customized basis so
here's our shared basis and these
this is a full or manifest so
those environment settings are getting
merged into this
and what the ci pipeline the ci cd
pipeline is doing
is it is going to commit those manifests
push those manifests into the staging
branch here
so it's still running at this point
okay so our pipeline is now finished
so if we go and look at our environment
repository
in our staging branch we can see that we
just
pushed new configs both staging and
production animals
we hydrate them all at the same time so
they're consistent
and see they are all fully fully
hydrated
manifests
so what that push did is that push
triggered a pipeline to deploy those
manifests
to our staging kubernetes cluster
that's now done so if we switch back to
cloud shell
now we can see what we have running in
our namespace
and our application
is now running and it's been running for
24 seconds so we have deployed our
changes
to our staging cluster now we'll quickly
promote those changes from the staging
branch into the mainline branch and that
will trigger the production deployment
so we'll go in here we'll make a new
merge request
okay we'll merge those
if we take a quick peek at the changes
here we can see that all we really
changed
was the hash
but that merge request has now triggered
the deployment to production so
we'll switch to our prod central context
and we can see that our new pods have
been running for about 14 seconds
so our deployment to our production
cluster is succeeded
now for the next workflow um as the
developer i've been talking with
the uh hipster shop front-end team that
they also have their application running
on our cluster
and they would like to be able to
connect to our
go application that we've been working
with so
what we're going to do is we're going to
switch over to the anthos config
management
repository so you can see
here we have all of our namespaces and
our cluster registries and that kind of
stuff
in there so what we're going to do is
we're going to make
a quick change to our network policy uh
to allow hipster shot front end to
connect to
our go app so
first before we get started here let's
take a quick look at our
current network policies
so we can see that right here we have
a uh just a default deny
for anything that's not within our
namespace so
and what we're going to do is we're
going to enable that
for hipster the hipster shot front end
so let's start again by creating a
branch
and we'll jump back over to our editor
and then here's our network policy that
is sitting inside of our namespaces and
our managed applications
so our go app
so this policy is going to allow traffic
from the hipster
front end to connect to our go
application
so we'll save that
okay and then let's push our change
okay so our change has been pushed so if
we jump back over to the get lab ui here
what we'll see is we just pushed
a new branch so since i pushed that
branch as the developer i'm going to
create a merge request
so we're going to allow traffic from the
hipster front end
so we'll submit that merge request now
uh our policy has been set up such that
i
am not as a developer i'm not allowed to
merge or to merge requests into
the main line so we're going to have to
uh
switch over to our network admin so now
i'm going to be our network
administrator
and we'll review those policy changes so
that way we can
merge that request in and allow that
traffic and while we're doing that you
can see that we've connect
we've kicked off another ci pipeline
where we're verifying
uh the changes that we're making to our
configuration
so we're running ci on our config on our
anthos configurations
let's switch over
and we have a merge request here so now
i'm in is the network administrator
and we see the merge request here from
me
uh wanting to allow traffic from the
hipster front end
into our go application so our while we
were doing that all of our test
pass so let's quickly view our changes
so there's our changes that we made look
good
so let's merge them
okay and now we're going to run ci
on them again just to make sure
everything is still good
and once when ci has finished we'll be
able to go out to our cluster and we'll
see that this
change has been applied and we'll check
it on both the production and staging
cluster
okay ci is finished so now if we jump
back
out to cloud shell and we look at our
network policies again
now we see that we're allowing traffic
from
application hipster front-end into our
into our go app namespace so
that process as a developer i needed to
make a network policy change i
made the change in the anthos
configuration management
repository and then that change was
reviewed and approved by a network
administrator
as we saw in the demo we had several
applications deployed
across a number of clusters both
pre-production and production
each application ran in their own
namespace or their own little playground
so that way they ran in an
isolated environment in order to allow
applications to communicate with each
other we had to involve
the operations and security team so that
way we could update the network policies
for those namespaces
and those policies and configurations
were being managed using
acm automatically being deployed and
reconciled across
all the clusters
now as a developer they can focus on
using a get ops workflow
so developers can build new features in
future branches and using tools like
scaffold
those changes can be automatically
deployed to a development cluster
so they can be live tested
when those changes are finished a merge
request is created
and when they're merged into the main
line the staging deployment is
automatically triggered by the
push of hydrated manifest into the
staging branch
of the environment repository
after those changes have been validated
on this aging cluster
the operations team or the developer
depending on your workflow can create a
merge request
to promote the configurations from the
staging branch
to the mainline branch and when those
changes are merged
to the main line the deployment to
production is automatically
triggered
so using the principles that we
described you are now
able to build upon a secure
platform where you're creating and
deploying your policy
using anthos configuration manager
you're storing that configuration as
code
so you automatically get the tracking
and traceability
provided by git and as you saw in the
demo
everything is highly automated from the
deployment of application changes
all the way through the configuration
changes that are
tested and deployed using acm
we're also using containers so we're
leveraging the immutable nature of
containers to increase the
reproducibility of our deployments
in our infrastructure and we're
leveraging anthos
and kubernetes as an open source
standards-based
infrastructure that you can then extend
your infrastructure
even further
brandon and i would like to thank you
for your time today